how serious is plague in 2022
it's still a big problem in many parts
of the world so just a few years ago in
madagascar they were taken by great
surprise in 2017 2018 when they had a
big outbreak
and it really caused panic there because
normally it's a rural disease it happens
out in poor areas of the country
and the wealthy and the cities don't
worry about it too much but they got
into the city and you know there were
thousands of cases and several hundred
people died
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kissin
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people doesn't get any more fascinating
and a little bit different to what we
normally do today because our brilliant
guest today is a professor of ecology at
greenwich university here in london who
is an expert in rats professor stephen
berman welcome to trigonometry hi it's
great to be here it's great to have you
on the show uh before we get into the
very interesting subject of rats tell
everybody a little bit about who are you
how are you where you are what has been
the journey through life that brings you
to be sitting here talking to us right
okay well you might hear from my accent
as we get going i'm an american i'm born
born in the state of maine up in the
northeastern part of the states
and so i did my first degree at the
university of vermont and then while i
was there i did an exchange program and
came over to the uk
and uh worked at the university of kent
on an exchange year
and
fell in love with the country fell in
love with a woman and decided to stay in
britain so i've been here ever since i
did my phd on on an insect called the
death watch beetle and now i work at the
natural resources institute which is an
institute within the university of
greenwich and the institute has a long
history of working in overseas
development research and linked to the
empire and
science in developing countries and
essentially on sort of tropical products
and how to to live there so issues with
locusts and malaria and the problems
there so that history of the of the
institute has been for several hundred
years working
in in collaboration with a lot of
institutions in those countries and so
my research is very much based on around
pest management issues whether that's
rodents which is a big part of my work
but also
other aspects around insects and the
management of crops and health issues
related to pests as well
and when francis was suggesting that we
get you on he was like oh we got to get
this guy on to talk about the
ratpocalypse
is there a rat apocalypse so are rats
about to take over the world well
there's a lot of them and i mean people
always have these anecdotes we're never
farther than six feet away from a rat i
don't really put much uh
in store on that sort of statement
because it does depend whether you live
in the city or in rural areas but rural
areas have lots of rats too i mean if
you live on a farm
and you'll just see rats everywhere in
the crop fields or if it's livestock so
there are hundreds of rats there in
cities such as london and new york and
paris there are big outbreaks of rats
they're living in the sewers they're
living in people's back gardens
and there is worries that the population
is growing i mean they are related to
our own agricultural production our
waste in cities these are all food
resources for rats so you know if you're
out in the garden feeding the birds or
in the park and you're littering all of
that is food for rats so
i think you know we really need to think
more carefully about how we interact in
the environment and how we might be
exacerbating some of these rat problems
the interesting thing with rats is that
wherever human beings went rats were
never far behind so we've always lived
together side by side even though we
found them disgusting that's right i
mean if you go down into some very deep
coal mines you'll find rats living down
there and antarctica where people have
gone for exploration we have mice living
there now so you know whether it's a
desert or a place where it's just under
snow all the time rats are living there
and adapting because we're there they're
you know taking advantage of our
accommodation that we provide or and the
waste that we produce and the food that
we produce so they've sort of co-evolved
with us and that of course has a lot of
implications in terms of disease for
example so because they've been living
alongside us they're going into really
dirty environments down into the sewer
and then coming into our kitchen and
spreading those diseases there so it's
a real problem that we've sort of
developed ourselves because of the way
that we're living and let's talk about
disease because
obviously they were responsible for one
pandemic a very very serious pandemic
could they be responsible for another
yes in fact if you think of the plague
which is what a lot of people talk about
in terms of pandemics there are actually
three uh pandemics in the history that
were related to plagues so there was one
plague before the medieval plague that
we talk about as a black death so before
that there was something called the
justinian plague which spread around and
then we had the the black death and now
we are
still within what is called the third
pandemic of plague which started in sort
of international transport steamships
going around the world with rats on
board and they spread rats to a lot of
parts of the world which had before not
had plague so to the americas
particularly peru and the southwest of
the united states also have
areas where plague can spread and we're
still within that technically uh third
pandemic still but besides plague
there's also been pandemics that have
been spread on other diseases so
hantaviruses it's a group of viruses but
in the time of the aztecs and the
spanish
colonialists coming over there was some
documented outbreaks of a hantavirus
which called massive population
collapses at the time
so we should be worried because of that
history but also i mean their role in
the current pandemic we know
quite certainly that rodents were not
the sort of the
development initial development of the
coronavirus that was most likely bats
but uh rodents were certainly involved
in the oberkron variant so what happened
is
uh you know the the virus has come out
it is now spreading a lot among lots of
different animal species not just humans
and has got into the rat population
although to begin with the rat
population was resistant to the
coronavirus but it's got in there and
i'll cause a lot of mutations so that's
how omikron is so different from the
original coronavirus uh variants that
were around so omicron was essentially
probably somewhere in southern africa
probably not south africa exactly but it
was mutating within mice and rodent
populations there and then came out as
it is now so we should still be worried
about other coronaviruses and and the
current coronavirus mutating possibly
more in rodents but i mean there are
many other
groups of uh diseases such as arena
viruses we should be worried about uh
one of the most famous arena viruses is
lassa fever which is really confined to
west africa particularly nigeria sierra
leone in those countries but there is
we've been observing over the last few
years really huge outbreaks and loss of
fever again out of context we don't
understand why was this climate change
is it something that we're doing that's
different but for the last few years
there's been massive outbreaks of loss
of fever spreading in new parts of
nigeria where in the in historical terms
they didn't really have much of any loss
of fever
and so there are other variants of lhasa
in in the americas particularly south
america and other parts of africa and
there are worries about these mutating
and spreading to the to other parts of
the world and
we need to be careful and start you know
doing water surveillance on some of
these other groups of diseases which
could result in a new pandemic
because particularly when you look at
new york or l.a that i was reading
reports that there's the bubonic plague
has returned to l.a that they've been
instances right i haven't heard about it
yeah yeah is that quite recent yeah yeah
in the last few years i mean obviously
there's a lot of problems with
homelessness and stuff like yeah yeah
and and it's it's not surprising i mean
the south west part of america where
plague is endemic in the wild so this is
like new mexico arizona quite close to
to la in that sense it's plague is a
disease like many of these born diseases
they're they are diseases of poverty so
they're often found on reservations of
native americans
where conditions are quite poor and
people are interacting
either with pet cats and the cats
acquire plague from chasing rats around
and killing the rats and the cats get
plagued and then you're cuddling your
cat and it coughs in your face and you
get plagued from your cat but of course
in other situations like l.a and sort of
poor conditions it might be through
direct contact with rats in in some of
the situations steve and what is it
about rats that makes them
so liable to transmit does is it how
closely we live together is it how many
of them there are or is there something
about the organism of the rat
specifically yeah i mean it is both of
those things it's the fact that they are
mammals like we are so you know they're
quite similar in physiology terms which
which is one of the reasons why we use
them so much in medical research and if
you're testing new drugs and things if
you first we'll often test them on model
animals and often that is rats and mice
but it is the fact that they're also
very numerous and a lot of these
diseases like plague are density
dependent so when you have a lot of rats
at very high density the disease spreads
in their population much much more
easily and the fact that they're going
from say these you know different
environments are going to dirty
environments where there might be a lot
of bacteria and viruses around and then
they can take those into into more clean
environments so that's i think quite
different from a lot of other diseases
we worry about because they just you
know they're in a single species and
they only have like a single disease but
rodents we know they can transmit more
than 60 different diseases to us some of
those are really scary diseases like
loss of fever with high mortality rates
a lot of them are just sort of
gastroenteric dysentery type diseases
things like salmonella and e coli and
they're getting into you know our food
supply you know contaminating in the
food processing side of things or if
you're living out in a rural area they
may be getting in your house and
contaminating the food that way
so what do we do with rats because
they've always been there they've always
lived with us
how do you control the population
because we're very advanced nobody has
been able to do it not easily and i
think this is one of the challenges and
and i think a lot of people
in the end they give up and they just
sort of live with a problem
and around the world where we've become
over-reliant on a single technology and
that's the use of anti-coagulant poisons
so these were discovered by accident
actually so in sort of the 1940s and 50s
uh this group of coumarin type compounds
were discovered that they lead to blood
thinning and prevent blood clotting we
now use them in in medicines and sort of
warfarin derivatives to thin our own
blood but in high levels of course it
interferes with vitamin k
and stops your blood from clotting and
the advantage of that with rodents is
that they don't notice they are being
poisoned so
with a lot of
the old poisons we used to use they were
what we would call acute poisons things
that are really really toxic things like
strychnine and things that you use to
murder each other which kill really
quickly and really painfully but the
problem with rodents is i mean they're
usually quite cautious when they eat
things so they come along and they just
eat a little bit
and they feel ill
and almost immediately so it's a bit
like us if we go off to a restaurant and
have a meal and that later that day we
feel really awful i'm never going to go
to that restaurant again you really sort
of link the two things together and
rodents are able to do that too if they
eat something and they feel a bit ill
fairly soon afterwards oh that was
really bad food i'm not going to eat
that and they avoid it so they become
behavioral resistant they didn't eat
enough of it to kill themselves so they
feel ill
but they because they're quite cautious
they just take a little bit so the
advantage of these anticoagulants that
were a fantastic innovation in the 1940s
and 50s is that they would eat it and
they wouldn't feel ill immediately
they'd go home they'd think about it
that was really good food and then they
come back the next day and eat more of
it and more of it and then they take a
lethal dose
and end up dying from it several days
later often
and
often they're you know because they feel
uh more tired so of course that's what's
happening is it's causing internal
bleeding
and so they feel sort of oh well just go
home and go to bed and that's often what
they do they go back to their burrows
fall asleep and die there
and
so it gets around a lot of the
behavioral issues with rodents part of
the problem with these compounds we're
having now is that they accumulate in
the environment so they don't break down
they've been synthetically designed
to last for a long time and so
non-target animals are picking them up
so predatory birds and other animals
that might eat the rodents but even
other things that are just in the
environment are also acquiring these
anticoagulant compounds so there's a lot
of legislation to try to stop using
these these compounds and getting that
balance right is quite difficult so some
countries are talking about banning them
entirely so we won't use anticoagulants
anymore others are talking about well we
need to regulate them better and make
sure that only professionals use them
which i think is fair enough you do need
to know how to use these things
carefully and to use them appropriately
and not just let any old person buy them
which in some countries is the way it is
so
we're in this challenge now where if we
do ban these things what are we going to
do
there really aren't any alternatives no
one has really done any further research
to develop new alternatives for rodent
control
there are some new things coming along
but nothing that has been commercialized
so one of the things i've been working
on is fertility control for example
contraceptives
which we know work with humans
and we actually do fertility control for
a lot of other uh sort of feral animals
whether that's horses or elephants to
control their populations in sustainable
ways but the challenge with rodents of
course is they're very prolific they're
very short-lived so how do you get these
fertility compounds in them and deliver
that in a way that would still limit
their population so there are very few
sort of alternatives some products on
the market some other kinds of poisons
on the market but nothing really works
so if we ban them we
you know then we have the opposite issue
where particularly farmers livestock
farmers in particular would be what are
we going to do about all these rats on
our farm if we can't use poisons
and i would say i don't know
honestly i mean poisons are you know
mortality control whether it's poisons
or using traps
traps can work in some situations but
they're very laborious to use so i think
in
you know europe and america with these
intensive farming situations having
someone go around and set lots of traps
all the time is is really not very cost
effective however in a lot of the work
that i do in africa and asia and other
parts of the world trapping i think is a
solution people you know can do it in a
safe way they don't need to use poisons
you can reuse the trap over and over
again and that's about communities
working together with those traps and so
we've been doing a lot of research on
that trying to to look at you know in in
small rural
uh communities where a lot of people are
involved in agriculture living in in
communities to try to use trapping as as
a means of controlling rat populations
and it seems to work
the problem is they're so small
they are smart but we must remember we
are smarter
and i think some of us anyway
people forget this people think
you know they they try to control rats
they put out some poison or they put out
a trap
and inevitably i will hear
within the population over time people
say oh they're too clever they're
avoiding our traps now
or they're avoiding the poison which i
mean they do learn they are behave you
know
they're mammals like we are they are
able to learn
there but there are limitations to to
what they're able to learn and i think
one of the challenges with a lot of
animals again it comes back to people
and our human perceptions we
anthropomorphize things we give other
animals human characteristics we do this
all the time with our pets our cats and
our dogs and
think that they're
you know being able to really love us
the way that we love them but with rats
we do the same thing i mean they're too
clever to control that you know we give
them abilities that they really don't
have
and one of again
sort of my jobs when i'm going out
working with communities to try to deal
with their rodent problems is making
people understand what are their
limitations what are their real biology
and behavior and how do you use that
against them so you know by knowing your
enemy you're able to to deal with it
much more effectively and i think people
they want to hear those things but they
you know they've had so much they have
so much cultural baggage sometimes with
rodents i mean here in our culture you
know we've got mickey mouse and all
these uh sort of protagonists and
stories that are all they're the good
guys you know the mouse is the you know
the main character in the story
and that i think clouds our judgments
sometimes and makes them you know into
these super human animals but
so i think yeah i was going to say on
the other hand though a rat's not part
because there are a few types of
a few species
that i think human beings evolved a very
strong aversion to from very early days
snakes spiders and a rats part of that
because
i mean a rat is basically a squirrel
with bad pr isn't it like absolutely
they're not that dissimilar it's the
scaly tail i think you know if you've
got a cute cuddly rat it makes a nice
pet and you know people will feed it
nuts openly in the park like squirrels
yeah but yeah rats and mice i think
because they're they're somewhat
nocturnal they sort of skid around
and that sort of look of the scaly tail
is what puts people off i also do think
it is related people have been able to
sort of put two and two together around
disease and hygiene and sanitation
issues and so again in our sort of mind
we realize these are things from from
you know going back thousands of years
we really should not be promoting them
and avoid them
hey kkk do you believe in spring
cleaning yes but only when my wife does
it in russia men who clean are executed
for not being real men which is correct
well for those men who are living in the
21st century manscaped has an incredible
offer for you manscaped are the global
leaders immense below the waist grooming
and have forever changed the grooming
game with their amazing performance
package
4.0 inside this care bundle you'll find
the lawn mower 4.0 trimmer weed whacker
ear and nose hair trimmer crop preserver
ball deodorant crop provider turner
performance boxer brief and a travel bag
to hold your goodies this elite trimmer
is designed to trim hair on loose skin
although your werewolves might look like
a couple of boris johnsons treat them
with respect and benefit from their
proprietary skin safe technology
complete your grooming game this spring
with the new refined cologne signature
scent by manscaped this stuff is legit
and will have you smelling like royalty
the good kind not prince andrew get 20
percent off and free shipping with the
code trigger20 at manscape.com that's 20
off and free shipping with the code
trigger20 at manscape.com it's time to
throw out all your old hygiene habits
and upgrade your life
and you you were talking about
population control before is
is that the only way to deal with it
basically to reduce the population of
rats or is there a way is there any way
to reduce the way they transmit disease
well there are other things we should be
doing and this is really again comes
back to human behavior it's about
sanitation and proofing and hygiene and
the way we manage our environment so in
a lot of urban areas we're just
we are the the cause right where you
know we're leaving food out and the bins
are overflowing this is just the rats
just come along and help themselves if
we did a better job at all that we would
have a major impact on rat populations
they just wouldn't they need food if
they can't get access to food then
you know they're just not going to be so
many of them around so there are a lot
of things that are you know proposed in
rodent professional management you know
you need to try to
make sure the rats can't get to the food
sources that's often very difficult if
say it's a pig farm or a chicken farm
and there's lots of animal food around
but in urban situations it really is no
excuse we should be able to do a better
job but the problem is is we don't
prioritize it we don't really understand
the impact and we're quite removed from
it i think ourselves we see them but
they don't really have a big impact on
our lives personally so we can just say
ah that's someone else's problem and
what do they eat
anything i mean it most rodents we must
remember that most rodent species
just live out in in the wild they don't
do anything of harm to us they're just
eating seeds they're usually green
everest so they're eating different you
know grass seeds and other things they
find in the wild they're part of the
ecosystem thousands of rodent species
live that way and don't cause us any
problems at all there's a handful of
species we call the commensal rodents
the pest species so these are things
like the norway rats and the house mice
that cause us problems they are more
omnivorous and i think that's something
they again they because of that
omnivorous ability to eat anything they
come across that means they you know
they can easily live in a city and live
off our waste
whatever kind of waste that is and
survive on it wow
you know sorry francis
i i remember when i was a kid i was
flying here from russia and there was a
guy on the plane with me who was on his
way to he ran an english language school
somewhere in east asia and he told me
the story about motorbiking around
thailand or whatever he told me a story
once he stopped to this guy's house and
because he was this western honored
guest
the guy you know wanted to give him some
meat so he he his wife went outside and
took a a rat off the drying rack and
served it
people
how
widespread is the practice of eating
rats around the world and you'll find it
in different cultures around the world
so some parts of africa and asia
particularly the rats are seen as a
delicacy
so
in west africa you have cane rats are
quite a big rat
often not very much of a pesky she's
living out in the wild but they do get
into sugar cane and some sort of crops
because they're so big and meaty people
are actually have domesticated them so
they're actually
grown as a farm animal and sold to local
markets that way and other parts of the
world as you say in southeast asia
sometimes they're served at weddings
because they're seen as this again a
sort of an idea of of fertility so the
young couple should be eating rats in
order to go on and debris and breed
themselves
and some places they're sort of tinned
up in like little tins that you buy in
the supermarket
you can get tinned rat you can mate you
look excited yeah in the philippines
they have something called star meat
rats spelled backwards
so if you go to the supermarket shelves
there and you find star meat that's rat
meat in a tin
so it's all been you know hygienically
produced and and
then
yeah yeah so i mean in many parts of the
world you know they're
they're eaten not just out of necessity
but because they really like eating them
it has a you know a very distinctive
taste
and that dust
and you know why not as long as they are
prepared carefully you're not leading to
some extinction you know in many you
know pest management uh ideas you say
well if you can't beat it eat it that's
one way of we deal with other pests but
there is a risk particularly with your
if you're catching a rat in the street
and yeah yeah and i think most people
where they do eat rats they make a
distinction between say house rats and
field rats okay and normally wouldn't
eat the rats that are from dirty
environments and are trying to to eat
them from from the field and why is
there a risk of eating a rat as opposed
to eating a chicken or whatever
well i guess it comes back to just the
number of potential diseases they might
be harboring and i think
often it's down to the to the way rats
are cooked
so i mean you can get very good recipes
and and things that will ensure that
they are cooked properly and you don't
have to worry about viruses and bacteria
being transmitted but because sometimes
they're quite small animals they don't
actually get cooked very well
so essentially they just held over the
open fire
and then you open them up and they're
still pretty raw inside and that's where
there have been documented cases of
people catching plague for example
pharyngeal plague where the bacteria
gets into the throat and then spreads
through the body that way and many uh
you know gastroenteric diseases could be
promoted that way particularly if you're
not gutting the animal you just eat the
whole thing which in some cultures they
do right don't have your wrap medium
rare
make sure
yeah
make sure it's well cooked and how
serious is plague in 2022
it's still a big problem in many parts
of the world so just a few years ago in
madagascar madagascar is a country
that's had
plague outbreaks almost every year for
the last 120 years wow so it's a chronic
problem there but they were taken by
great surprise in 2017 2018 when they
had a big outbreak
that got into the capital city in
tenerife and to other urban areas and it
really caused panic there because
normally it's a rural disease it happens
out in poor areas of the country and the
wealthy and the cities don't worry about
it too much but this particular outbreak
again it started in the rural area and
it got into the city and then it started
transmitting human to human which is
what you know if you go back to the
black death that's how it was primarily
being transmitted first it comes from
the rats but then it gets into your
lungs and you cough out an aerosol of
blood that someone else immediately
inhales and catches plagued that way so
that's what was happening in 2017 2018
in madagascar in the city
all the cases were pneumatically
transmission transmitted from person to
person so it caused panic and you know
there were
thousands of cases and several hundred
people died
and because i always understood that it
was transmitted by fleas that's right
that's how it still is classically
transmitted so it lives in some rodent
species again most of these species are
living out in the wild they're not
really interacting with humans very much
they
they act as a reservoir for the plague
bacterium in their bodies and they don't
seem to get ill from it
but then what can happen is those rodent
species come in contact with other
species that are living in our cities
the the urban rodents
and so either the rodents themselves or
the fleas jump off those rodents and get
onto the other rodents and those rodent
species recall are susceptible so they
do fall ill eventually and so you can
get what are called rat falls or mass
die-offs of rats in cities that contract
plague and then all the fleas on their
bodies leave and then what do they look
to bite well they bite us because we're
the only other thing around to bite and
that's how the primary transmission of
plague occurs if it's not treated
eventually it spreads through your body
you get you know widespread septicemia
it gets into the blood it gets into the
lungs and that's how you can then
transmit it human to human through sort
of coughing out blood that's got the the
bacteria in it so it's highly
transmissible then once it gets to that
once it gets to that point well i mean
even at the bubonic form it's still a
very pathetic bacteria so with bubonic
plague you get this the classic symptom
is the swelling of the buboes the lymph
nodes yeah so it's either in your neck
your groin or your armpits you get these
big swellings which in medieval times
was well documented and it's a very
classic symptom of plague which no other
disease really has
but if you get pneumonic plague
essentially you cough and you inhale it
and it just you know rapidly
your lungs you have pneumonia you die
from that but bubonic plague can also
kill quite quickly if left untreated and
that's one of the challenges in many of
the countries that continue to have
plagued people don't seek treatment
quickly enough antibiotics will clear it
if you go to the your doctor and get the
antibiotics but if you live in a very
rural area maybe it's days to get to the
doctor and to then recognize its plague
and be treated it's often too late and
unfortunately people are dying of a
disease that is curable quite easily in
the right situation and what's the
likelihood of of us having that type of
disease in the uk or the us well we have
these huge rat
populations but we don't but we tend to
have better infrastructure yeah a plague
has been used as a terrorist weapon in
the past and there are still worries
plague being used yes it was used by the
japanese on mainland china so they
loaded up ceramic bombs with fleas
infected fleas and dropped these over
cities
to try to uh you know
cause an outbreak it's it's more about
panic than anything but you know it's a
kind of biological weapon right since
the russians learned how to uh put it
into big intercontinental ballistic
missiles with the bacteria itself
so the america the americans look we
will send you rockets full of reds
the americans tried to do this but they
could never get the bacteria to maintain
its virulence
in large cultures but did the russians
the russians did this and so they had
these huge labs
where they were using you know growing
this bacteria they had to keep doing it
all the time because the bacteria would
eventually lose it's very so they're
recycling the plague in these and these
missiles all the time so at the fall of
the soviet union all these uh areas like
in kazakhstan and elsewhere where they
had these uh big uh plague uh centers
they had to shuttle that down
so
[ __ ] you know yeah but here now i think
our risk of playing naturally is very
limited right so
one of the things we know about plague
in modern times is wherever it's endemic
it tends to be sort of a semi-arid
environment at high altitude so if you
think of the the the plateau of
madagascar in the middle of the country
it's quite high altitude the southwest
of america mexico arizona against a
mountainous region the central area of
asia where plague evolved you know the
steps of kazakhstan and that sort of
area again is a sort of semi-arid
savannah like environment which is why
again it spreads a lot in africa in
general in those sort of habitats so
europe is not a natural place for plague
the climate is wrong here
so but of course in those days you know
it spread human to human you don't need
the rats and fleas anymore in fact we
had plague outbreaks in in the time of
the black death in countries like
iceland where there were no rats
so that we know at that time there were
no rats in iceland yet they had plague
outbreaks because it was just going from
human to human either through us
coughing out an aerosol or possibly even
through human fleas
so in those days of course you know
hygiene standards were a lot lower
people you know they would move around
they'd have human fleas all through
their clothes people didn't wash very
often their clothes weren't washed and
they were sleeping in communal beds and
going to inns which were infested again
stories of you know being bitten by
human fleas
by the thousands and so we of course
don't have great evidence of it but we
suspect that those human fleas were
probably transmitting plague throughout
medieval europe at that time and francis
mentioned the huge rat population uh in
different cities around the world do you
have an estimate of how many rats there
are in the uk
uh more more than there are people by
far
but it's a real challenge to put your
fingers in it's a lot of effort to try
to get those estimates you know to go
out and do a traffic it's a ballpark
like there's 70 million people in the uk
approximately oh it's at least three
times that many rights so there are 200
million rats living in the u.s i would
say easily it's probably much more than
that there have been some studies that
have tried to understand how many rats
are killed just in agricultural
production so if you think about you
know the large cereal crops you've got
rats living out in those fields
and they're just you know living in the
soil burrowing and they're eating the
the wheat or the maize or whatever it is
and you you they till the soil which in
itself just chews up lots of rats
and it's literally billions of rats
around the world and those sort of
situations are just being
destroyed in agricultural production
right so here in the uk of course
there's a lot of livestock farms that
are heavily infested there's a lot of
cereal crops where again there's just
rats living out there taking advantage
of that and you know that's in a rural
area where again we may not really
observe it very much probably in the
cities i don't think that you know the
rat problems are very high simply
because again it's just access to food
and things so i i would say the rural
population is probably a lot larger than
what you have in urban areas yeah but i
suppose the rural population is less
problematic quote unquote it's the city
rats people don't see it i think you
know that's the thing you know in urban
areas you know i think you know during
the pandemical there was a sort of
increase in reporting of rat out rat
numbers and i think a lot of that's
because people were sitting at home
looking at what's going on in their back
garden and the local restaurants were
running and so the the sort of
traditional sources of food that people
had
for rats you know the the bins at the
back of the the takeaway were not there
so the rats said well where else are we
going to go so they went into people's
gardens and so there was a big reportage
of more rats around even though probably
the rat population was declining during
the pandemic because there was less food
around in urban areas and so what other
impact do they have particularly in
cities we've looked at the disease
element of it which is of course huge
but what other impact do they have
well i think one of the most traumatic
things that i've seen is people have
been bitten by rats and it does happen
here in the uk i mean it's not often but
you know there are stories in the in the
sort of more tabloid press here of mum
being eaten alive by rats
and you know this is usually someone
who's very ill in a care home and can't
fight off the rats and you know they
show pictures of her elbow all bitten up
by a rat that just keeps biting her
in many other parts of the world it's
much worse where you can see uh babies
with their noses bitten off entirely and
you know sort of real sort of slum
conditions where
these rat bites you know maybe 10 of the
population that's routinely being bitten
by wow rats while you're asleep at night
so you're in your house you can hear all
the rats running around and they're
crawling all over you running over you
while you try to sleep and a lot of
people complain of disturbed sleep but
then if you know if you've if you're
sweating or you've got food residues on
your
on your hands or something like that the
rats will come along and just start
licking
they're not trying to eat you usually
but then you twitch in your sleep and
then they bite out in self-defense
really so some pretty grotesque pictures
and people that i've seen who've had
really terrible terrible experiences
where then it leads to infection
and gangrene and people having
amputations because of it and you know
just getting wrapped by fever which
again is through bacterial infection
getting into into the wound and
spreading through the body so rat bites
i would say is one thing that i would
try to avoid
uh in terms of you know food
contamination it's really hard to to put
your finger on it again it's an anecdote
we know rats are involved in salmonella
transmission
but to what extent
it's again it's a question of how much
do we want to invest in trying to
understand what the real impact is in
food production particularly i think we
massively underestimate the impact but
no one's looking
and i think with a lot of rat issues
it's we just don't want to hear about it
we want to brush the issue under the
carpet we don't want to spend money on
it
and
so we don't know it's the answer in many
of the situations
and what about the aggressive nature of
rats because that's something that gets
talked about a lot if you corner a rat
it will go for your throat is this true
or is this how is a rat gonna go for
your throat
you're six one and a rat is this big
yeah i mean right no they're about that
big rats can be quite aggressive and but
i mean i think most animals are if
they're cornered so you know if you've
got one in your garden shed and it can't
find the way out to get out i mean its
response will be to try to attack you to
get away you know i mean some of the
the the norway rats you get on farms or
in urban areas around here they're very
big sometimes as big as your domestic
cat
and if you've got a small cat i've got a
small cat at home and certainly some of
the rats i've seen are bigger than my
cat and if that's battle sort of
situation you can see a rat winning in
some of those situations it's going to
go for your throat is that why we're
having this conversation you're scared
of a rat
yeah i mean they they would certainly
try to attack you but i suspect you
would
well you'd be so either so scared you'd
run out of the way yeah or you would
find your way of dispatching it
yourself that's what i would say and
then load it into a rocket and say a lot
of people get quite queasy about that
just let you know run away themselves
yeah it's it's really interesting and
and steve what are you working on in
terms of your research now are you
trying to find solutions to some of
these problems or you
yeah i mean there's various angles some
of it is about sort of developing new
alternatives for the poisons
and so fertility control is something
we've been looking at in a number of
different countries evaluating its
efficacy so one of the challenges here
is you know it you've got a large
population of rats that turns over very
quickly so how do you deliver
something like a contraceptive to a
rodent in a food base so it's
essentially you have to put out a bait
it's usually got a poison in it will it
work when we put the fertility control
in there
and again it comes back to humans and
the perceptions of that you know a lot
of people say why are we just going to
stop them having babies we want to get
rid of them
and so a lot of it is
trying to make people understand that
actually this is much more sustainable
more humane for starters but actually is
more ecologically sustainable than
trying to kill them so if i can try to
explain to you what happens when you do
mortality control is you kill off a
whole bunch of rodents but you don't
kill them all it's impossible to kill
them all so those that are left recover
very quickly they go through very rapid
breeding
and rodents are very good breeding
machines so they they can do something
called postpartum estrus so that means
as soon as they give birth they can get
pregnant almost immediately the next day
they can get pregnant again so they
still have a young litter that they're
they're nursing so if it's a mother rat
she's nursing one litter and she's
pregnant with the next
and as soon as those babies are weaned
and go off into the environment she's
giving birth the next day
so the gestation period and the weaning
period are are coinciding number of days
so essentially every month most species
of rodent can have another litter of
young wow
they're just pumping them out so if you
kill a bunch what you're doing is you're
suddenly opening up the habitat yeah
there's a lot of food around because
usually the food production is going up
this is the beginning of the cropping
season
and so those babies realize well they
have a better survival because there's a
lot more food around there's less
competition because you've killed a
bunch and so they go through a
population explosion and the population
actually can go higher than it would
have
if you hadn't done any mortality control
so it overshoots and this is common with
a lot of pest issues that we control
this way with fertility control you stop
those animals from having babies in the
first place they're still there they're
still eating something
but the population of course can't
exponentially grow as the food
production increases so it's
more sustainable but people need to see
it at the end of the season in a sense
so they have to be patient understand
that the damage to their crops is going
to actually be lower because you've
managed the population and stopped it
from going through this boom and bust
phenomenon so what we try to do is work
with communities so they can understand
that
but also it's all about timing when you
deliver this bait you don't want to just
do it all the time so you really want to
just deliver it once ideally and have an
impact throughout the next few months so
a lot of the research researchers trying
to understand these ecological issues
and different sort of context making to
making it work so that's a a big part of
my work another part of the work is
trying to really understand the role
between rodent control and disease
transmission
so again it gets quite complicated in
ecological terms and essentially you
think fewer rats should mean less
disease transmission
and with some diseases that's probably
the case but with other diseases
possibly not so what can happen when
again you kill a lot of rats or remove
rats whether however you do it
those animals that are left might move
around more
so they come in contact with more
animals further away and possibly spread
the disease
and make so you make matters worse
so the and so trying to understand these
dynamics is is another sort of
fundamental issues for so for example
with plague in madagascar we're trying
to control rodents but then what happens
to those fleas and could you actually
make matters worse if you kill those
rats the fleas come off
are we responsible for causing a plague
outbreak by killing rats so
it's it's really tricky sometimes and
sometimes these different diseases have
different ways of sort of surviving some
get into
water or soil and then are transmitted
that way
and so that's another big component of
my work is trying to understand what is
the best way of managing a rodent
population to stop humans catching some
of these diseases
hey constantine do you love trigonometry
i'm from russia i cannot love anything
apart from vodka miserable literature
and a horrendous downfall of my people
but yes i find trigonometry satisfactory
and do you like live shows of course but
only if it's check of play about
collapse of russian aristocracy as they
face death and obscurity before the
glorious might of the proletariat and
the beautiful revolution
okay mate well if you like trigonometry
live shows then get your credit card out
for the lads because we're coming to the
edinburgh festival this august we have
only booked two shows august 6th and 7th
because if we do more the comedy
industry will treat us like the tsars
and execute us that's right we're going
to be in edinburgh for two days only
saturday's guest is andrew doyle which
is sure to sell out our other guest is
leo curse which means when nicola
sturgeon hears about it she'll ban us
from scotland herself tickets are sure
to sell out and when they're gone
they're gone click on the link below and
we'll see you in edinburgh on the 6th
and 7th of august at the gilded balloon
teviet come and see us before hordes of
left-wing comedians try to put us in
gulag
and steve there's also a problem as well
isn't there the
the rat is also celebrated or even
worshipped in some countries i remember
seeing a documentary about rats and
there was a rat temple in india yep
there are those rat temples if you if
you look at the hindu god ganesh you'll
often see him riding a rat like a horse
you're seeing you know he's perched on
top of a rat and that's his moses
transport and again i mean because rats
and their their status as a fertility
symbol people revere them in that way
and these uh temples in india people
openly feed the rats because the rats
are servants of the gods again to to
ganesh and others so by feeding the rats
you are you know helping
feed your gods in that sense so it is a
challenge in some communities i mean if
you think of the buddhist religion where
you shouldn't harm animals how do you
reconcile that with pest control and
killing things like rats it's often
quite difficult to and you know it
requires again understanding human
psychology and why we do what we do in
order to really control a pest problem
like rats and what happens when you have
like a rat temples for instance in india
is that does that then become a hub of
disease
we have tried well not me but some of my
colleagues have looked into that because
you get these big basins of porridge and
sort of milky substances which are
there and the rats are coming along and
eating from that
people have tried to test those
substances but so far
i think it's inconclusive that we've
found i think there is quite high
turnover so you know that food is
constantly being replaced because
there's so many rats living there
and the people who visit there i mean
again
you would really have to do quite a
careful study and i don't think that's
really happened to understand again
maybe because people don't want to know
the answer
it's better not to know
so it's interesting our aversion to rats
is not universal around the world
no not at all i mean even in european
and western society
people have pets
pet rats you know the fancy rats they're
just nicely colored norway rats or mice
you know people have them as pets
they're quite affectionate i mean most
of these rat species that are pests are
also very social
so you know that makes them nice pets
because they can be quite affectionate
in that sense so i mean there's a huge
industry around that which is
also caused some ecological disasters
for example in the pet trade so the
there's a species of rack called the
african giant pouched again it's a big
rat long lived species so people like
them as pets
they have been sent off
around the world for pets and
unfortunately they've escaped in the to
the florida everglades oh wow and they
are now a pest species there that is
driving its own
uh invasive ecology within invasive
pythons
so again the pythons have escaped from
the pet trade living in the other grades
eating these uh african pouched rats in
the everglades as well because it's
caused ecological disaster in the
everglades because a lot of the native
species they've all been destroyed and
competed by these species but also i
mean these pouch rats have been used
very nicely in helping us clear
landmines for example so that you might
have heard of the hero wrap program or
the popo program it's uh developed by
some belgian colleagues and tanzanian
colleagues where they're using the smell
the acute sense of smell of rodents
they're very good at smelling things out
and they train the rats to smell tnt and
bombs
and so they they've learned how to use
that smell to them you know they have
the rats and they go through this area
of field where they suspect there were
landmines and they've trained them when
they when they smell tnt they make like
a little digging
behavior and then they get a reward
piece of banana or something to and then
someone can come in and clear that field
of bombs the way that dogs are used but
rats of course
are perhaps a cheaper alternative to
that they're also using rats to detect
tb and screen tuberculosis
which is a huge problem in many
developing countries and it's really
hard to
screen normally it means usually a human
staring down a microscope all day and
often makes a lot of mistakes because
they get tired but again the rodents are
able to smell the bacteria in a sputum
sample so you can just line up a bunch
of these patient samples
and the rat just walks up and down and
smells which ones have tb
and so it's and they're very very
accurate much more accurate than than
humans are
that's incredible because there is a
flip side to the right and that we use
them like you said in medicine yeah and
the the
practically every drug we've ever had
has been experimented upon brands yeah
yeah no way and this is the the i think
one of the trade-offs or or the balances
you know we want to
i think a lot of people see them with a
version but i think we have to admire
them too i mean they they're we use them
in many ways but also just if you if you
think of the diversity of rodents and
diversity and biodiversity is really
important and there are really there are
more species of rodent than all other
mammals put together they're you know a
highly uh successful group of animals
living in the wild and it's because of
these these teeth they have you know
they have these big incisors it allows
them to chew through a lot of materials
they have no intention of eating but
allows them to get into new habitats you
know they can
you know get through your door or
whatever barriers you might try to put
in front of them and so you know that
evolutionary behavior
has allowed them to you know be quite
successful in the world
just some of them are good
not all rats
but i i've always found them so
fascinating you know what what is it
what is it what was the thing that drew
you towards them
i really got involved by accident i
didn't start out as a rodent expert and
i think that's
something that you know some of my
colleagues would also come from that
background we often get involved
through pest management which is often
focused on insects around the world a
lot more people work on insects than
rodents in academia
and
so i you know when i started working at
the natural resources institute i was a
trained entomologist an insect person
and
sitting around the table one day you
know we had a
request from someone in mozambique
asking for for help and expertise on
rodents i had done a little bit of work
on rodents as an undergraduate at
university so i put my hand up and they
said fantastic off you go to mozambique
and i just learned it all there you know
i was sent out to these villages where
people were complaining of
mainly post-harvest losses
so this is after they harvested their
maize crops they were storing them in
their house all stacked up inside these
maze crops and the rats were living in
the grass thatching of the root roofs
just living up there nesting there and
coming down and eating their their maize
stored in their houses
and of course being bitten with plague
and all these other problems and so we
started trapping in some of these houses
and i was catching on average 100 rats
in a house wow these are you know tiny
sort of mud thatched buildings one room
everyone sleeps together and the food is
there the kitchen is there all together
and all these rats are up there and
very little was being done about it so
you know that kind of
opened my eyes to a problem that was
being neglected and i felt well we need
to do something about this
poisons weren't really an option because
they were eating rats in these
communities as well as a source of
protein and so we started this
trial on you know how can we just trap
them out can we trap them intensively
enough with the labor on hand and all
these households to do something about
it and from there you know i started
making contacts with the rodent
community i'm not the only expert in the
world there are many very well
well-respected colleagues who've been
doing it longer than i have
and uh so i started talking to them and
then
developing more grant proposals and
doing more research in different parts
of the world and but we've also touched
on the impact they have the negative
impact on ecology like you said the
everglades and wherever human beings
went rats were very close behind and
then they succeeded in wiping out they
do they they're invasive and you know
this has been a big problem on islands
around the world where again you've had
these sort of bird populations that
aren't used to having rats around we've
accidentally introduced rats and they
just devastate the population you know
they're
they may be flightless or they're
putting their nest scenario where the
rats can come along and attack the
chicks and eggs in their nests and so
yes we we have tried to reverse that so
there are some people who have learned
how to very efficiently remove rats from
islands at great expense but you can be
done and we've done this quite
successfully in in many small islands
and even some large islands
new zealand is even trying to do this
across the entire new zealand
you know two big islands they have a
a program to remove not just rats but
all introduce species so which again
have caused ecological disaster in new
zealand for a lot of native bird species
and things so they are essentially
starting
on this idea where we will clear parts
of the island and then they put a huge
wall around that part to keep out all
these invasive species and then the idea
is those walls will expand and expand as
they clear more and more of new zealand
of all these invasive species so i wish
them luck as a huge challenge but they
seem very dedicated to it it's often a
family activity to go out hunting on the
weekend trapping these species out not
just rats but you know opossums and
other things that they've had there to
try to bring new zealand back to the way
it was before all these invasive species
came in
and and how likely is it that they're
going to achieve their goal
if they're if i think they could if
they're you know they have to put the
money into it and the manpower into it
and you know if they keep it up and it
seems there's a lot of buy-in by
the community you know the people of new
zealand have you know they understand
this is important
and this is what will do it if you know
the if the population is behind it and
puts the money into it and the labor i
think they could do it it may take a
while but they already do have some big
parts that are sort of already cleared
around something you know national parks
and things like that where they've been
able to do this successfully so it's
just a matter of being able to expand
that across uh greater and greater areas
of the country and and where do they
originate from then so it's not from
australia or new zealand or those people
south america well it will depend on the
species if we're talking about rattus so
we have rattus rattus which is the black
rat which we don't really have here
anymore but it used to be a big problem
here and now we have norway rats
ratchets norvegicus so rattus is a genus
that evolved in asia particularly
central asia so that's where the ratchet
species are so if you go to southeast
asia you will find a large diversity of
ratchet species and they're all quite
similar they all often look the same
it's really hard to tell them apart but
there's a big diversity there in other
parts of the world they have other
groups of pest species so for example in
africa the main genus is called mastomus
or the multi-mammot rat it has lots of
nipples and able to have very large
litters so it's a it's a big problem in
africa so there are these sort of global
invasive species like particularly
rattus and house mice
musculus these are the species that have
really spread around in urban
environments and when they have invaded
new places they've often you know
resulted in extinctions and other things
uh being removed from that those areas
but then there are often sort of local
pest species so in south asia you have
band dakota species which again look
quite distinctive you get them in india
and bangladesh and pakistan and they
really are confined to to that region
steve it's been an absolute pleasure and
fascinating conversation before we ask
you our questions from our supporters uh
we always end the show with one final
question which is i know you're probably
going to say razz but i'm going to ask
you anyway what do you think is the one
thing we're not talking about as a
society that we really should be well i
mean the institute i work at is is very
much involved in overseas development
research so i think that's one thing i
would like to highlight is that i think
we we sometimes live in a bubble we
don't realize how
difficult it is in other parts of the
world and i would really encourage
people to start thinking about how can
we support
more research to to deal with some of
the problems that we we have in say
africa and asia some of these issues are
really simple to to to deal with but we
just need to do some basic research on
it so i would really hope that people
will think more about
what other people have to go through
living with rats or whether it's other
pest problems we hear about malaria but
there are so many other neglected
problems and you really have to make an
effort to inform yourself about some of
these issues sometimes because there's
just so many competing interests and
rats i think are neglected despite you
know myself spending so much time on it
there are very few of us working on this
and there are so many other neglected
issues like this so try to go out and
inform yourself on some of these
developing issues and i would say you
know one place to look at is my own
institute natural resources institute to
try to find out some of the other things
that we're doing
steve it's been an absolute pleasure if
people want to find you online where is
the best place to do that go to the
university of greenwich natural
resources institute and there's a little
uh page up there about all the staff
involved so if you just google my name
and you will find plenty of links that
way professor berman thank you so much
for coming on and thank you guys for
watching and listening we will see you
very soon with another brilliant
interview like this one or raw show all
of them go out at 7pm uk time and for
those of you who like your trigonometry
on the go it's also available as a
podcast take care and see you soon guys
do they really come up the toilet or is
my local plumber having me on